you guys know about all this craziness
related to uh wokeness infecting all of
our institutions and destroying pretty
much everything whether it's educational
institutions political institutions
corporate institutions entertainment
institutions beer institutions like
Budweiser the parent beer of Bud Light
owned by Anheuser-Busch of course and
what sparked much of the latest brouhaha
was that Bud Light sponsored Dylan
Mulvaney this is a dude dressed as a
chick hi impressive carrying skills
right I got some Bud Lights for us so I
kept hearing about this thing called
March Madness and I thought we were all
just having a hectic month but it turns
out it has something to do with sports
and I'm not sure exactly which sport but
either way it's a cause to celebrate
this month I celebrated my day 365 a
Womanhood and Bud Light Sent Me possibly
the best gift ever a can with my face on
it check out my Instagram story to see
how you can enjoy March Madness with Bud
Light and maybe win some money too love
ya
here don't love you back uh okay you
guys know the Fallout from this thing
Bud Light is stuck on shelves
Anheuser-Busch offered like this
half-assed apology I think they like
suspended or slightly removed with pay
the woman who's in charge of this they
were embarrassed by their own customers
I mean just an absolute catastrophic
mess for the company and I have to say
it's good to see because one way you can
push back against this nonsense is with
your dollars now you might be going Dave
why are you showing me this this thing
happened you know a month ago six weeks
ago whatever it might be there is a
reason because at night I do watch I
usually watch old Carson tonight shows
sometimes I watch Seinfeld I watch old
Simpsons episodes things like that but I
was watching a Johnny Carson Tonight
Show last night with it was a guest host
so it wasn't Carson hosting it was Joey
Bishop was guest hosting this has got to
be around 1975. they go to Commercial
and they have Ed McMahon doing a
Budweiser commercial sort of in studio
so watch this and just see how in 40
plus years how things have changed so
drastically it's this is just great
watch this
[Applause]
and now here speaking in round figures
for the king of beers is Ed McMahon
did you ever think about all the
sandwiches that are consumed across the
country during just one evening's
tonight's show
for example there are thousands of
loaves of bread hundreds of slices of
cold cuts
jar after jar of mustard
actually tons and tons of pickles
and when all those sandwiches are
enjoyed
here's a safe bet on what's being
enjoyed right along with them
that of course would be Budweiser Bud is
the largest selling beer in the world
here's a beer that makes it body clear
what taste is all about so raise your
Stein at the friendly sign but wiser
king of beer
if you're planning an icebox raid
tonight
yourself a Budweiser to go right along
with that sandwich
it could possibly cost a little more
but as the echo says it's that Budweiser
taste that makes it worth it it is worth
it
it's Budweiser
how different in 40 something years I'm
not even telling you that was the
greatest commercial ever or any or how
marketing was or anything but just the
simple fact that back then all the
Budweiser wanted to do with cell beer
and they thought that was an effective
way of doing it
[Music]